[Musica]
il vino è da dove cominciamo dall italia
sì perché il vino arte e cultura quindi
in quanto tale e cittadino del mondo ma
viva l'italia
ovviamente il film in italia è nato
un'ottantina di anni fa il vino di
qualità 80 anni fa quando tra gli altri
un grande enologo che è stato il padre
dell'energia moderna ha fatto sì che il
blend del prodotto avvenisse attraverso
dei vini già fatti e non delle uve cioè
le uve messe insieme ciardone grechetto
siepi stato no brand vini fatti ecco
questo fatto ha segnato l'energia
moderna quindi non è il sacrificio del
cristo non tanto meno le nozze di cana
ma 80 anni fa circa e questi 80 anni
oggi possiamo dire che il vino italiano
equa 17 degli hard disk arsi di valore e
cinque miliardi e mezzo di bottiglie per
quanto riguarda la qualità del vino cioè
nel senso della qualità della quantità
del prodotto del denaro
siamo secondi per quanto riguarda i
prodotti venduti cioè il numero di
bottiglie siamo i primi al mondo
un paese che produce vino lo produce
bene è un grande paese è un paese che
produce il vino di qualità è un
grandissimo paese un paese che è diverso
dagli altri perché mentre l'italia mille
forse 2 mila cucine italiane
la francia ne ha 2 e il paese italia è
la somma dei vitigni che è molto
superiore alla somma dei vitigni del
mondo immaginate quanto importante
questa ricchezza e non è finita qui la
nostra ricchezza e la diversità
noi non andiamo per denominazione di
origine
andiamo per tre per proprio per luoghi
per la differenza dei vitigni per la
differenza dei luoghi per la differenza
che il luogo stesso dalla differenza al
vino uno chardonnay dicono che è un
vitigno internazionale
ma se questo vitigno internazionale che
si chiama chardonnay lo fa per esempio
un certo produttore siciliano e quando
lo bevi sente il profumo della zagara
come possiamo dire che è un vitigno
internazionale uno chardonnay che sa di
zagara da qui voglio dire canta in
quanto è importante la diversità del
nostro paese della nostra ricchezza e la
ricchezza che avrebbe fatto ricco il
paese italia se avessimo puntato tutto
sulla nostra diversità la diversità
nell'arte ma l'arte del vino ma l'arte
del cibo la qualità le zone che fanno la
differenza nel nostro paese rispetto
all'appiattimento dei dei profumi e dei
sapori del resto del mondo non abbiamo
compite competizione in questo noi siamo
il paese più ricco al mondo per la
diversità della nostra ricchezza e la
cosa più bella che c'erano sopra essere
quella che fa accapponare la pelle
quando si comincia a studiare il vino
quando si capisce a capire e vino e il
vino che si capisce soltanto se con un
anno e mezzo due anni ci lavori sopra
non si può dice questo è buono e questo
non mi piace
non si è capito il vino pensare che ci
siamo contati 200 mila persone circa
oggi conoscono il vino e 61 milioni di
persone non sanno che cos'è non sanno
che cos'è nel senso che non hanno
cambiato la vita in meglio per averlo
conosciuto nelle sue tradizioni nelle
sue diversità come ho detto prima ma
soprattutto conosciuto alla qualità
delle centinaia e centinaia di
possibilità che vino italiano ma anche
di uno del mondo ha nel farsi ascoltare
e farsi sentire
ecco questo senso questo senso deve
conoscere il vino di raccontarlo del
poter dare una qualificazione a questo
prodotto è che un po
la figura del sommelier ri insomma chi è
che ormai non è questo questo uomo che
versa il vino questa donna a questo
ragazzo che verso il vino nella nella
nell'osteria nel ristorante ma la
professione somigliantissima inizia
innanzitutto viene assunto presso le
aziende vitivinicole il sommelier re
colui che vende il vino prima è il
ciabattino vendeva le scarpe vendeva
anche il vino oggi ci vuole un somellier
per vendere il vino quindi un agente di
commercio abbiamo aperto 8.000 wine bar
e osterie dei nostri bisnonni soltanto
negli ultimi 20 anni
immaginate questa imprenditoria
giovanile che cresce a fianco in un
consumatore attento e preparato perché
entra in questo wine bar osteria da
soldi della tartari 7 entra per
associare dei vini particolari dei
prodotti particolari fa tardi la sera
con la sua ragazza
parlano delle loro cose dei loro amori
dei loro affetti mentre bevono un grande
vino mentre bevono un grande prodotto un
nuovo un nuovo sistema di passare da
sera e poi bank scrivono le edicole oggi
sono piene di giornali di vino c'è molto
scrittura di vino
e poi c'è l'insegnante del vino vedrete
quanta quanta quanto mestiere gira
intorno al vino oltre che quello del
produttore ovviamente che al momento non
ci interessa
e quanto il produttore riceve da noi
degli input affinché possiamo dirgli
cosa vorrebbe cosa desidererebbe un
consumatore attento e diamo notizie al
consumatore attento di tutto quello che
sta facendo un produttore quindi un
tramite vero e proprio il sommelier che
che fa da arbitro in questo gioco
meraviglioso che è il vino il vino
racconta la storia millenaria di ddt
territorio ovviamente c'è una storia che
non sto qui oggi per i minuti che
abbiamo
raccontarvi neanche minimamente di
quello che è la l'avventura che ha
portato avanti il prodotto vino in
questi nostri ultimi mille anni
ma una cosa è certa che va capito che va
studiato che va raccontato nei suoi
minimi particolari c'è un sud del mondo
che esce benissimo allo scoperto le
qualità e abbiamo detto ma c'è un sud
del mondo la nuova zelanda la strada e
cile l'argentina e sudafrica che sta
facendo bene e che sta facendo dei gravi
e c'è questo turismo internazionale del
vino un turismo grandissimo importante
se meno che se il dato che mi è stato
dato nel 2014 meno 22 per cento e
turismo di qualità nella città di roma
oggi si sta elevando un turismo del vino
fantastico siamo due libri che ho sulla
mia scrivania che si chiamano camere su
vigna vedo dei risolte nati con
dell'eleganza pazzesca mostruosa la
bellezza la professionalità di chi
gestisce questi alberghi che hanno le
camere sulle vigne questo territorio
disegnato dall uva questa italia
disegnata dalle linee è una cosa
fantastica
quindi si appropria il vino di un
turismo di qualità che sta scemando
nelle grandi città del nostro paese il
turismo il vino porta il turismo
telefonare a un numero per venire a
visitare la vigna significa visitare la
vigna che si darà la cantina fare delle
degustazioni passare una giornata
diversa e soprattutto acquistare dei
vini direttamente dal produttore
un produttore che se tu lo conosci
quando vai a casa senti che il vino più
buono è un mondo quello che deve
riempire di tanti circostanze
circostanze katie katie elevano katie
katie katie formano e che ti fanno
capire sempre non è mai mai finito quel
giorno di non capire
di capire meglio il vino perché il vino
e l'evoluzione nella consapevolezza che
ti deve trasmettere delle emozioni alla
sua consapevolezza di trasmettere dei
territori delle delle considerazioni del
che a questo prodotto che non si ferma
soltanto ad una semplice bevuta che non
è certamente una sbevazza ta al vino ma
che c'è un matrimonio da fare
un matrimonio d'amore tra il cibo e il
vino
questo matrimonio è l'abbinamento del
cibo con il vino e non non sarebbe
assolutamente possibile pensare che il
vino bevuto da solo sia un significato
al significato è veramente quando lui
sposa un cibo e lì quando riconosciamo
la qualità e il modo di abbinate al cibo
al vino perché non ho fatto prima perché
non hanno scoperto prima che quello era
il vino abbinato a questo piatto è
questo piatto poteva essere abbinato
questo vino e questa è la forza di un
prodotto che ti dà la certezza
matematica dell'entusiasmo di provare se
conosce il vino e se conosci il vino sai
quando devi smettere per questa ragione
noi diciamo che il vino fa bene fa bene
perché chi conosce il vino sa quando
deve smettere il vino non fa male
un messaggio francese ai bambini di 4
anni è chiaro nella scuola è questo due
punti
il vino fa bene il vino è cosa buona
il vino è un angelo non è un diavolo
pensate che i bambini di 4 anni poi
vanno più in là ciclo scolastico
e quando arrivano nel processo mi pare
intorno ai 16 anni 15 anni quattordici
anni quindi anni da insomma fanno due
anni di vino a scuola per cui il
dentista quando inizia a mettere le dita
nella bocca della gente ha fatto due
anni di vino in francia e in italia
nella scuola alberghiera italiana scuola
deputata all'ospitalità in cinque anni
di programma non c'è neppure un'ora di
meno
ecco perché il mio amico che mi ha
presentato ha detto abbiamo fatto tanto
si è ben fatto tanto tantissimo abbiamo
fatto abbiamo rovesciato per certi
aspetti e le sfere della non conoscenza
del vino dove hanno fatto poco perché il
vino va raccontato almeno per un anno e
mezzo più 23 anni e mezzo no per essere
vero per far conoscere il territorio in
italia del mondo per far conoscere ai
ragazzi
l'effetto che fa il prodotto dal punto
di vista geografico per far sì che
questi ragazzi non abusi daranno mai di
un prodotto così importante come il vino
perché troppo importante e quindi per
questa ragione noi tentiamo
disperatamente di arrivare giorno dopo
giorno con un passaparola a raccontare
il vino e a cercare di ridurre quella
enorme quantità di persone che non
conoscono il vino e sono milioni sono i
60 milioni di prima
quelli che il detto ma forse non sanno
cos'è e non c'è un fatto di ricchezza no
perché il vino non costa non ci ho fatto
il ricco non conosce il vino lo stesso e
non è ricco e comprendono perché è ricco
non lo compra perché non ha cultura del
vino
abbiamo vari episodi ma non me li
racconto perché forse aggravano ancora
più la situazione di questo nostro paese
cerchiamo positivo di andare avanti in
positivo è cercare di conoscerlo questo
prodotto di amarlo di rispettarlo e di
far sì che questo prodotto non diventi
un fatto negativo perché il paese ancora
non è preparato per dire ad alta voce
che il vino non è una negazione
pensate che quando ho chiesto al
ministro di parte di parlare di più di
vino a linea verde dato che maurizio
martina paga questo programma l'inizio
dell'estate
mi sono sentito rispondere
un po più in là quando il palinsesto era
già fatto franco guarda che c'è un
regolamento che il vino a mezzogiorno
sta in fascia protetta
ecco io non faccio nessuna
considerazione se non quella che ho
fatto a lui bisogna cambiare il
regolamento ci sono delle idee troppo
strane nei confronti del prodotto
ci sono delle idee troppo strane fa male
non fa male non mi interessano noi non
interessa è il conoscerlo che mi
interessa è conoscere questo aspetto
naturale questo aspetto di cultura che
ha il nostro paese ed è conoscere
soltanto che voglio io
nessuno poi abuserà di un prodotto se è
buono se è un angelo non si abusa
davanti alle cose interessanti le cause
di cultura le grandi culture
ecco io vi ringrazio della vostra
attenzione mi auguro di conoscerlo e
vino di amarlo
perché il vino vi cambia la vita in
meglio qualunque mestiere andato a fare
nella vita
anche il medico l'ingegnere farete
meglio l'ingegnere e farete meglio il
medico se conoscete lina e vi auguro
sempre a questo sempre per tutta la vita
libere le vostre migliori bottiglie
soltanto quelle persone che amate
grazie
[Applauso]